oh hello people it's uh lewis again big
lou
uh
for all the emotional appeal seldom
suffices
if i know when i come down here
and tell you guys story for you guys to
identify with them they got to have
depth and weight that means i got to
tell the truth from the bone to the
heart
so i come down and i lay it on y'all
i'll give it to you just like it is
uh i think about some nouns i
learned when i was about five years old
stupid dumb worthless
idiot dumbest dummy of all
[ __ ] dummies those were the words i
heard when i was a kid those
of those are the nouns that they gave me
the names that they gave me when i was a
kid and to this day
to this very day to [ __ ] now walk
with me
i mean i lay down at night and i think
about them and and they bring up things
that happen to
occurred in my life and i in a sense i
wonder whether things that occurred in
my life did they have
were they pertaining to what i was
called to what not i don't know
i'm no political scientist or anything
like that
one of the stories i was thinking about
that happened to me you know i always
try to
tell things that i don't want to i'm
going i'm going to tell what i don't
want to tell you first i really don't
want to tell anybody this because i
really have never ever ever
told anybody this well
lionel trains have always been my i love
me a lionel train i've always been crazy
about lying on trains well
i've always been crazy about southern
pacific trains because southern pacific
trains would always come you know
through the neighborhood into the
children already neighborhood we lived
in and mom used to take me down to the
track sometime and we sit there in the
car and i was just i would just love to
watch them go across that track
when they go cry just love to watch them
[ __ ] trains
so one time we said we i had some
friends that we used to hang around with
and then we had
we had a guy who used to tell us uh
he was telling us like like urban
legends and stories we should love to
hear him tell stories
one day he sit down and he says well man
you you like these uh you seem like
these trainers they got a train show
coming
over in the uh oh no and then in the
tent over there next week and you know
you
you my friend he wants to take over to
the train show so you watch some trains
so he takes me to the train show we get
there and they got man they got
they got they got a train that goes up
on top of the ceiling going around they
got they got they got a passenger train
up there they got a southern pacific
train going around the middle they got a
santa fe blue a little blue and gold
santa fe train they ran
right around along the bottom the bottom
there so i'm watching trains and i'm i
think i'm about i must be about
six or seven years old and i watched the
train so this guy's this was this guy's
this guy's
his white guy's kind of got his xylon
he's looking at me but i'm you know i'm
a little kid i don't know what's going
on you know
and they couldn't get me out of there
because when i once i once
when i'm i'm really turning back a
little bit my mom took me to a car show
one time and she didn't have enough but
to get me and my brother in there
she put me in there and i stayed in a
[ __ ] place for 11 hours didn't think
nothing about them i stayed in that
place for 11 hours my mother was
so mad at me and heard my brother had to
stand the way to be when i get so when i
get
when i get into it so i was into the
trains like that so my friends left me
there to at the at the tent
but there's just there's just there's
this white guy man and he uh
he just insisted that i would come you
know he had he had to say well i see you
like that you know you like the freight
train up here and you like the santa fe
trains he's oh well i got a couple of
trains at home and
enough you want to come by the house and
look at some trains so yeah we
we job pretending like my dumb something
through me
something told me something in my back
of my mind told me don't get in that car
with that man i don't know
i got in that car anyway and now we went
to his house and um
he had the trains and we had the trains
and he had i remember i just fight that
that uh nestle quick chocolate milk you
know the nasty quick talk about
i remember it like it was yesterday now
he's like he has to make a mess
some chocolate milk that he that he gave
me i'm just
oh it's hard it's gonna be hard for me
to get this one out because this is this
is a tough one
how do you get off of it so
he had one train that that one trainer
ran in
in a figure eight that ran the problem
wrong along the floor
and he told me he said whoa one of the
one of the one of the little wheels that
came off the track
and he goes he said well he used to bend
down there and get the wheel off the
track
i got down and got the wall off the
track and i should have known he was
moving he was he was he was kind of
moving up in his chair you know but i'm
a kid i don't know
about no no man messing with me and
another kind of [ __ ]
so i'm here i'm over the chin i remember
oh my god he grabbed me by the i was
down like this he grabbed me by the neck
like this and he pulled me up like this
and he said
he said pull your pants down put your
pants down i'm like what what no
you should pull your [ __ ] pants down
so he made me pull my pants down and uh
he tried to sodomize me but his penis
hit oh god i can't believe i'm telling
us but his penis wouldn't fit in he
tried to sodomize me
and uh after he got through
he kind of okay so the way he the way he
had me he had me by the neck like this
and through the legs some kind of way
in some some kind of way i slipped
through i slipped through and i slipped
out and i
remember when i ran out the door he told
me he said
if you ever tell anybody what i did he
said i'm gonna bring you back here and
i'm gonna cut your ass so
i'm going to he said i'm going to cut
your i'm going to cut your [ __ ] open
or something
something whatever he told me he scared
his shot at me
so i ran all the way home i went on my
way i know must be about a mile or two i
ran away home and um
i was down south at the time and my
i never told anybody i was i was i
i would take that to the grave because i
i thought i thought that i was i heard
all these that what made me say well i
thought about all these things that they
call me
i said well maybe that's what that maybe
that's why this guy tried to but
i was so young i didn't know that that's
i don't know and i but i was just scared
me to death
i don't know i didn't i didn't know what
the i don't know i didn't know i didn't
know anything about a serial killer or
murderer or anything
maybe the guy was a serial killer murder
i don't know but i remember um
he said if i didn't know and i i i
wouldn't tell anybody because
i just i remember what he said i thought
he was gonna catch me and cut me up or
something so
one day i was my okay
side of the family the black people are
white they're all like
hey the high class white people driving
nice cars but the
black people on my mama's side they all
[ __ ] i mean they [ __ ] she got some
brothers and these [ __ ]
she got some brothers she got three
brothers and these somebody's they when
they walk down the street
[ __ ] move out toy i'm talking
about they get out the [ __ ] way
i ain't [ __ ]
so anyway they haven't been in my house
that day you know
now it was this is about six months
later
and this is bothering me this this this
had really [ __ ] bothered me you know
i mean come on man i'm a six-year-old
kid
some man tried to put his [ __ ] penis
in my ass i didn't know what the hell
was going on
and and and and anyway
this particular guy and they were there
there were a bunch it was like
like like downsides there were a bunch
of drunks and they would i know they
were drunk now i know they were drunk
because i'm a drunkard
but they were oh hey how kind it was
like some black guys for white they
would all kind of hang out down on us
like down the stream around the corner
at this little convenience store it's
the piggly wiggly store they'd hang out
there in front of a drink beer and sit
out in front of it with them little ford
green truck one of them had one of them
had a lime green truck but anyway
my uncle said what's wrong with you boy
i was i started crying you know i'm just
sitting there crying
my uncle said what's wrong with you boy
i said nothing i'm stuck in here
i'm sucking this over all day long he
was asking me
what's wrong with you man what's wrong
with you
what's wrong with you i broke down i
cried i cried i couldn't stop crying
i said this man this man tried to put
his
damn my butt now
i'm glad so i'm glad i told them but
when i tell you what he did what my
uncles did to him
let me get to the story i never forget
the expression on my uncle's face
he said what the [ __ ] you say he said he
is here he said what the
[ __ ] you saying as this [ __ ] he
called his brother two brothers they was
all in the name of mom he said
get your ass in the truck we finna go
find the [ __ ] i'm like okay
yeah we're going to get them back we
don't know i don't know what i thought
they just gonna cuss him out or say hey
man
they were just i mean they were these
guys they're so big they could look at
you man you're [ __ ] you i'm your
[ __ ] [ __ ] my uncle they said
if they set them and look you're gonna
[ __ ] your you going straight [ __ ] your
pants let me eat some big
big [ __ ] so anyway
we're riding around this truck and we
buying ice cream and i'm scared that if
i'm shaking
because i'm thinking to what the guy
told me he was going to [ __ ] kill me
and i
think i'm going to die i'm going to die
i'm going to die and all day went by
because
i was at first we couldn't find him so
i'm happy we couldn't find him because
because now i don't have to be reliable
for telling i figured my uncles are
going to forget about it everything was
going to be going about it
we went around to the piggly wiggly
store
dead the [ __ ] was him and three
other white boys were standing there
and i remember we my
uncle i gonna say was driving it was
what i was and i was on
the this side he was in and he stole the
truck down i looked he looked at me and
i guess i don't know what my uncle saw
the truck down
you can hear one of them say [ __ ]
[ __ ]
that's all she wrote marco i said that's
him
my uncle went around the corner he
parked the pickup truck
he said well he's he said we're going to
wait till we go each i'm going to wait
till i see this [ __ ] all by
himself
i'm sitting there you should have saw
the expression on mother you showed a
song you should have saw the tear you
should have i
remember that [ __ ] like i was in it i
was shaking i was so [ __ ] scared
i was in the truck shot cuz i didn't
know what's gonna happen
i vague remember
they caught him by his shelf
they beat him in the face or michael's
put him in the back of the pickup truck
put a puppet put up put a pair of
handcuffs on his arms
hog tied his legs and we went to there
was a there was a there was a
there was a barn that was like a couple
a couple of houses down from
where the piggly was and there was a
store like a stormwater i guess where
they store their
milk and [ __ ] when they got it and they
grabbed this man out of his truck
oh my god this is that scene
and he drove him in the barn and
god i never never i never told about
this oh nobody can't go to jail but they
don't like those uncles
they had a table laid out on the table
they put him on that [ __ ] table
my uncle had her not not not not the
louis vuitton
the short one i could still hear that
man screaming
and he didn't hit him in the face he
kept hitting him he bit him he beat him
but he was big
he was beating him and he just my
[ __ ] nephew my mother [ __ ]
that you did [ __ ] my
he said no no no no no i wasn't me
anyway he kept saying i
wanted me and what he said with me
mother was waiting on his face man
i mean every time he hit him i was just
white you know white his face was
turning blue and [ __ ]
he [ __ ] up and said yeah i did it
[ __ ] you in that little [ __ ]
[Music]
god i don't know i don't even know if i
can tell this okay
uncle had up um in the back of his
pickup truck he had a
um the kind of broom that had a stick
that goes like this
i'm trying to figure out what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] he gonna do already
beating with it with the bat what's he
going
he took this stick
and he broke the tip of the stick and um
he pulled that man's pants down put that
stick in that man's ass
and and and and and god i i
i i could i could i could still hear
that i could still hear that man i never
heard a man scream like that because it
was so far in the bunker nobody seen him
and what made it so bad god i never told
him about this
god don't let me go to you
michael had a mallet and um
he said you will never ever try to [ __ ]
another kid you never try to unless
my nephew's not asking everyone he said
why did you why my nephew why my nephew
why my nephew why am i there
so i don't know i don't know i don't
know [ __ ] it do what you're
to go take that mallet and he hit him
two times
in the ass that mallet oh my god i could
still
i could i can still see the blood coming
from his ass man
i blood shot at his ass like i mean i
like like a like a
like squirted out of it and that man
i've never i've never heard a man
holler like that man i was hunting like
a three-year-old giant man i was
hollering i [ __ ]
i know somebody had to hear him and the
[ __ ] up thing about it was
he was handcuffed in a hogtie by the
feet
and they left him there to this day
through this day
i don't know if he died if he didn't die
we know nobody ever said a damn
thing about it so you know
that happened to me
for six months but six months after that
i'll say about five or six months after
that i didn't say a word
you couldn't get me to say hi because
they they had we had a saying when we
were we were little they said sticks and
stones can break my bones but words
would never ever hurt me and i knew if
even though that man did that to me
i've always i don't know i've always
been a horse i still i just
to see that stick up his ass like that
man i just god
damn i kind of feel not so i guess i
feel slightly
but i i never forgot that you know so i
said
if if what i if if i can say something
to somebody
and then make somebody kill somebody
like that and i had to watch that [ __ ]
as a [ __ ] six seven-year-old child
i need not talk no [ __ ] anymore i
shut the f i shut down
they had to take me to a [ __ ] side
cop because they
they couldn't figure out what was wrong
with me
i saw a man get sliced by the ass with a
stick and a goddamn matter that six
years old he tried to put his [ __ ] in my
damn ass
now this has you you know by then as
young as a child i was i was [ __ ] up
behind that [ __ ]
i was [ __ ] up behind that [ __ ] that
along with the women making me do [ __ ]
and all other [ __ ] reminded me making me
do this [ __ ] so that made me kind of cry
but i think i think even through all of
that kind of [ __ ]
now even though that [ __ ] still affects
me i think i didn't do too bad cause it
didn't drive me all the way crazy you
know what i'm saying
though i do have my moments where i do
have my moments i do
sometimes people sometimes people make
me so mad doing little bitty [ __ ]
so i want to tell i'm really i want to
hurt them real bad i mean i just i just
want to
i think about that kind of [ __ ] and [ __ ]
people didn't mean when i was little and
i want to hurt them
real [ __ ] bad i want to do some some
damage to [ __ ] you know i just
want
this now i've never i think it
i think it in my mind i'll be sitting
there thinking [ __ ] you don't
know what happened when i was little i
see you talking to you you don't know
who you [ __ ] talk to because i'm
the kind of [ __ ] i've been on
you you know you know what i
i watch these programs on tv and i see
these guys and they
and they're they're they're [ __ ]
serial killers
and i'm thinking god how could that ki
how could that [ __ ] get good looking
kid like me how could he do that
but then when they go back and tell when
they when they go back and tell i think
that's why i like those stories so much
i watch them on tv because when they go
back and tell us the
psychologists get a hold of him before
they lock him up before they kill him
they want to know
why and some of those guys are both like
me they'll get out there and tell it
the guy said one you know he said when i
was little boy either when i was a
little boy my father he's i said
one kid said he used to watch his father
[ __ ] his little sister and he made him
watch and he made him made him tag along
and that kind of [ __ ] we made him grow
up and then he would
he would he would stab and we'd stab the
animals
cut the animals up in front and that
kind of but that made the guy turn into
a [ __ ] serial killer so that so see
sometimes i think like that
and i say i i i obviously there's
nothing wrong with me because
he thought like that i think like that
too man i be one of the [ __ ] i before
man some of the some of the [ __ ] that i
think about doing the people some
i don't i don't so much think about it
doing [ __ ] like that so much now because
i'm not gonna go
get locked or behind on [ __ ]
bars but you know this [ __ ] leads all
the way up into my
at least all well into my alcoholism
when they first offered me their joint i
took that joint jimmy
chad and offered me that johnny dead
joining i got cool calm when they gave
me that drink
i drank the whole bottle threw up one
another hey this is why i drink
this is my medication this is my this is
my where i can you know where i can kind
of you know
i guess i can medicate you know i can i
can push this [ __ ] down i can drown it
in there and ain't never got to worry
about it even though the pain is in
there the pain ain't never going away
they never go go away
but the pain is still down in there you
know
oh that was a deal that was that was
real hard to get off of ah
but i felt a whole lot better good job
let me roll along before i start crying
because i
i i didn't i didn't deserve that i
didn't deserve that
no [ __ ] kid deserves to get hammered
in the ass and watch somebody get
halfway killed no
no kid deserve no [ __ ] like that i mean
i walk with this [ __ ] they eat
but i told somebody
that wasn't too bad wasn't
you